I learned this a long time ago cuz you
ever you ever hear people say thank God
it's Friday oh god it's Monday live
their whole life thank guys Friday Oh
guys money hump day those are people
that are surviving they're a rat in a
wheel they're just trudging along got no
plan living for the weekend that's what
you know that's those people right now
let me tell you what the statistics tell
us the research tells us about those
people they do not progress in their
life or in their wealth building and let
me say anything it's not growing it's
dying people who have wealth starting
from nothing which is the majority of
people who have wealth they started from
nothing when interviewed and they asked
them their decision-making paradigm they
said I make decisions like career
decisions or purchase decisions or
investment decisions not based on what
will make me feel good Friday but what
will make me win 10 and 20 years from
today if your decision-making paradigm
by which you analyze and create a plot
critical thought to your decisions
because it makes you ask yourself how
does this decision affect me 10 20 30
years or for that matter in eternity it
will cause you because you're aiming at
the moon it will cause you to jump
higher climb faster and go bigger
because you have a higher bigger goal
Abbey Haig my friend Jim Collins calls
it a big hairy audacious goal but if all
you're doing is saying cut if I could
just get till Friday
let me just tell you all you're gonna do
is just get to Friday the people on the
lower socioeconomic rungs of the ladder
who stay there have short-term very
short-term decision-making paradigms and
so they do rent-to-own because you would
never pay payments rental payments on a
couch if you were
thinking long term you would never pay
rental payments on a washer and dryer if
you were thinking long term if you're
thinking long term you would pay cash
for a used one at a garage sale because
there's no payments you know one invests
for retirement less they're thinking
long term
no one saves further kids college unless
they're thinking long term these are all
activities of wealthy people but you
always see short-term thinking lotto
winner you know the lotto tickets almost
all your lotto tickets are sold in the
poor ZIP codes in town oh but it goes to
education that's great let's have poor
pig of Ehrman plan for you let's put it
out there this this possible way let's
tax the poor so we can send middle class
kids to college for free and say we won
ding ding that's what my state does
we're so proud we just took money from
poor people in the Scent middle class
people's kids college for free it's a
great program well something that some
lower class kids go to college but you
know who really goes when you'd analyze
zip codes the people that take advantage
of the lottery winning I thought the
lottery winnings the lottery
scholarships our own middle class
there's a few lower class but it's
almost all lower class zip codes that
pay for lower socioeconomic zip codes
that pay for the lottery so why because
you're thinking short-term mean they say
stupid stuff like how I just pay for fun
I you know what I've got a long time
losing money has never been fun to me
that was fun it's lost some money that
was a blast
see that's short-term thinking if you
put the same amount into a mutual fund
in a Roth IRA that you put in your
stupid lotto you could retire
millionaire that's fine
it's not funny stupid
it's a tax on people that can't do math
that's what the lottery is it's
short-term thinking and this is where
all the stuff all the short-term
thinking is in that end of town if you
want to get out of that into town start
thinking long-term hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]